bonjour niel motivé mon coude est notre
invité politique ce matin vous êtes
député la république en marche les
yvelines président de la commission des
lois à l'assemblée nationale on est
ensemble pendant 1 minute pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale bonjour ça faisait
un bon jour du groupe les journaux
régionaux de l'est de la france est
justement qu'on va parler de la crise
annie t on va parler de se marier au
micro une piste il a été détecté dans
l'est de la france conseil de défense
sanitaire lundi c'est ce qu'a annoncé
hier le premier ministre en place jean
castex à l'explosion des cas face à la
montée en puissance de ce variant mikron
est ce que le gouvernement ne tarde pas
trop à mettre en place de nouvelles
mesures et est ce qu'il faut de
nouvelles mesures pour nous nous avons
fait à l'assemblée nationale une
audition ce mercredi de du professeur
delfraissy président du conseil
scientifique qui nous a expliqué et
détaillé la situation ils nous ont
montré aussi avec le professeur
cauchemar des projections et l'impact
que différentes mesures peuvent avoir
sur l'évolution de l'épidémie donc il
faut en fait suivre la situation au jour
le jour c'est ce que fait le
gouvernement est très réactif on voit
bien que dans une crise qui peut évoluer
très vite il faut agir vite et c'est
l'idée derrière ce conseil de défense
qui aura lieu dès lundi et pas mercredi
comme il est d'usagé donc grande
réactivité face à une épidémie il faut
quand même se rappeler qu'on est dans la
cinquième vague due aux variants delta
c'est bien ce que le professeur
delfraissy nous a rappelé est pas encore
là sont des tas de cd4 séquençage sont
ses conséquences est important de le
rappeler ils nous ont dit que l'impact
d'une troisième dose serait plus massif
si nous étions en population générale et
non pas uniquement sur des personnes de
plus de 65 ans avec un effet qui va
varier du simple au double sur l'impact
de cette troisième dose donc mais juste
on m'a traîné le gouvernement il nie ce
beaucoup sur la vaccination on l'a
compris est là l'allergie la campagne de
3e 2 est-ce que c'est suffisant miser
sur la vaccination quand on voit qu'on
peut être vaccinés est contaminée et
trans alors non ce n'est pas suffisant
le professeur delfraissy nous l'a dit
elle nous a dit qu'en fait finalement
c'était ça l'explication finale
aujourd'hui la france était un petit peu
meilleure que certains autres pays qui
étaient eux tout aussi vacciner c'est
que la france ne s'est pas relâchée
concernant les gestes barrières on est
un des rares pays qui a conservé un très
haut niveau de protection en termes de
masques en termes de distanciation
sociale en termes d'accès dans des lieux
publics avec le pass sanitaire est en
fait ce bouclier de protection
il permet à notre pays de tenir donc il
ne faut pas miser tout sur la
vaccination la vaccination c'est un
outil indispensable donc la vaccination
plus gestes barrières parce sanitaire
distanciation ses locaux à
saint-jean-d'angély tracté sur le mât
sanitaire jeu long oui c'est un c'est un
outil dans un dispositif global aucun
outil dans cette crise ne nous permet de
faire face seul c'est cette combinaison
qui va nous permettre de réussir et
c'est la responsabilité de chacun de
continuer à se protéger à protéger les
autres c'est l'une des inquiétudes des
français c'est de devoir avoir recours à
des méthodes plus radicales je pense
notamment au confinement total hors
confinement total ou partiel est ce
qu'on va pouvoir y échapper c'est ce que
l'on souhaite c'est ce que l'on souhaite
tous parce que on a tous beaucoup
souffert déconfinement successifs nos
enfants ont terriblement souffert d'être
éloignés de leur lieu scolarité donc
pour l'éviter c'est ce bouclier multi
avec des dispositifs multiples tels que
je vous les ai exposé et nous espérons
grâce à ça tenir mais encore une fois il
ne faudra pas hésiter si malheureusement
la situation s'aggrave à prendre des
mesures plus importantes et cette
situation est très évolutive donc il
faut être très réactif et ce n'est pas
parce que à un jour donné nous avons une
position que cette position doit tenir
la semaine suivante où le mois suivant
savez moi j'ai toujours
l'habitude de prendre une image par
rapport à un voilier un voilier mais
dévoile selon un vent d'une certaine
force et puis quand le vent faiblit ou
forci eh bien on change les voiles et il
faut réagir vite et c'est ce que le
gouvernement doit faire et le parlement
doit l'accompagner en ce qu'il doit lui
donner les bons outils pour bien réagir
moi je me suis bien des débats
parlementaires où on disait il n'ya plus
besoin de passer ni terre il ya plus
besoin de régime d'état d'urgence
sanitaire au cas où la situation
s'aggraverait eh bien c'est faux la
situation nous montre aujourd'hui qu'on
a besoin du passé ni terre et que
malheureusement peut-être un jour on
aura encore besoin d'avoir des mesures
plus graves nous ne souhaitons pas mais
c'est possible donc il faut envisager
toutes les possibilités c'est notre rôle
aujourd'hui dans la bouche des mesures
pour qui elle pour une pile et en
allemagne il ya des mesures qui sont
mises en place mesure très restrictif
pour les non vaccinés uniquement est ce
que c'est un scénario qui vous paraît
envisageable en france alors la
situation n'est pas la même en france
parce que nous avons des plus de 20 de
personnes vaccinées nous avons un pass
sanitaire qui est efficace nous nous
pensons aujourd'hui que le cadre légal
qui est le nôtre et le bon en ce qu'il
conserve les équilibres entre une
situation sanitaire grave donc il faut
faire de différence dans les mesures
entre vacciner mon métier ça ne me
paraît pas nécessaire et je crois que ce
serait même contraire à
nos grands principes qui guident notre
action autre débat en allemagne c'est
sur la faction la vaccination
obligatoire pour tout ce débat va être
ouvert il va être discutée au parlement
avec une application possible en février
ou mars on se lave en der leyen elle
même a dit qu'elle était favorable aux
vins cette discussion dans l'union
européenne est-ce qu'il faut ouvrir
cette discussion en france les sénateurs
socialistes ont tenté de le faire ça a
été rejetée est ce que finalement il
n'avait pas un temps d'avancé vous savez
on a posé la question pareille au
professeur delfraissy en commission il
nous a dit que lui à titre personnel il
était contre cette vaccination
obligatoire pensant qu'elle ne serait
pas forcément
très efficace et que nous n'avons pas
les moyens de contraindre des personnes
allaient se faire vacciner donc encore
une fois nous aujourd'hui nous n'avons
pas fait ce choix maintenant la
situation est encore une fois très
évolutive nous ne savons pas s'il faudra
aller jusque là aujourd'hui ça n'est pas
en tout cas ce qui est retenu moi
personnellement je crois qu'il faut
rester dans une politique très
incitative s'en allait vers l'obligation
autre sujet on va parler ce qui se passe
au parlement les députés qui ont donc
voté l'allongement du délai légal pour
une pour une ivg de douze à quatorze
semaines voté par les députés mais
françois patriat nous annoncer sur ce
plateau que les sénateurs de la
république en marche ne le reprendrons
pas dans leur niche parlementaire
c'est-à-dire pour le monde pour le
moment ce texte n'est pas inscrit au
sénat y ne poursuit pas son parcours son
parcours parlementaire est ce que vous
le regrettez moi ce que je regrette une
façon générale c'est que les
propositions de loi et du mal à suivre
un parcours parlementaire
équilibré c'est d'ailleurs la raison
pourquoi pour laquelle moi j'ai
formulées dans un rapport des
propositions qui viendra en parler voilà
mais qui permet rien mais sur lee mais
je vais faire cheminer c est ce que vous
regrettez vous reçoit patriat ne met pas
inscrits dans ces entités moi je crois
que chacun dans ces niches gère ses
priorités j'ai cru comprendre qu'il
préférait m inscrire un texte sur le
harcèlement scolaire qui concerne
presque un million de nos enfants et qui
est un thème très grave et c'est un
texte qui vient d'être votée à
l'unanimité à l'assemblée donc moi je
crois que ce choix en ce qui concerne la
gestion de sa niche et le bon même si je
n'ai pas à me prononcer sur les
inscriptions au sénat de certains textes
mais en tout cas voilà moi je pense que
la priorité la lutte contre le
harcèlement scolaire moi ça me va très
bien on peut quand même s'étonner que ce
que vous êtes une étonnante du
bicamérisme voulait il est très attaché
nous d'entrer régulièrement on peut
quand même s'étonner qu'il n'y ait pas
eu de concertation en amont entre les
parlementaires de la majorité de
l'assemblée et du sénat sur ce sujet il
y a toujours ce dialogue après chacun
fait ses choix et c'est bien heureux moi
je suis tonnante du bicamérisme mais
justement avec l'indépendance liés à
chaque à chaque chambre donc peut-être
qu'un autre groupe pourra inscrire ce
texte sur une niche vous savez que le
texte était initialement sur un telle
issue de
le faire est ce que vous souhaitez que
le gouvernement le fasse écoutez moi je
pense que quand il ya une discussion
parlementaire qui est ouverte il est
toujours heureux qu'elle aille jusqu'à
son terme donc si le gouvernement
pouvait l'inscrire sur son ordre du jour
au sénat je trouverais ça bien
simplement parce que je pense qu'encore
une fois il est dommageable d'ouvrir des
discussions et de ne pas les terminer
vous êtes favorable où elle ce texte moi
j'étais assez assez réservé je suis très
favorable
évidemment à l'interruption volontaire
de grossesse en ce qu'elles puissent
être pratiqué par tout
lorsqu elles le souhaitent et donc il
faut vraiment faire en sorte que ce soit
un droit effectif sur toutes les parties
de notre territoire après
personnellement effectivement j'étais
assez réservé sur l'allongement du
groupe pourquoi parce que j'ai entendu
les spécialistes j'entends les collèges
notamment de gynécologie qui dit que
c'est un acte plus invasif que c'est un
acte plus graves l'interruption de
grossesse est une souffrance terrible
pour chaque femme qui y recourent quels
que soient le moment et il me semble que
plus on avance quand même dans le temps
plus l'acte est invasif et plus la
souffrance peut être grande honte moi
j'ai su réserver mais je comprends que
d'autres aient des avis de différent
c'est toute la beauté d'un parlement qui
délibère qui débat et qui au final
vote est tranchée justement vous faites
des propositions vous pourra réformer le
fonctionnement parlementaire lesquels
effectivement moi je souhaite renforcer
le parlement pour moi il part il
m'apparaît que c'est une réponse une des
réponses à tout le moins la crise
démocratique aujourd'hui on a entendu
beaucoup nos concitoyens nous dire le
parlement ne sert à rien on n'est pas
représenté au parlement vous êtes une
chambre d'enregistrement vous ne jouez
pas votre rôle de contrôle de l'action
du gouvernement
il me semble à travers ces remarques de
nos concitoyens qui ne veulent pas
supprimer le parlement mais qu'au
contraire ils veulent un parlement qui
joue pleinement son rôle et c'est ce que
j'essaye de faire à travers ce rapport
et ses propositions donc un parlement
qui maîtrise mieux son temps qui
maîtrise mieux son ordre du jour qu'ils
puissent mieux faire cheminer justement
les initiatives qui émane de son sein
qui émane de ces travaux parlementaires
on dit souvent les travaux
parlementaires ce sont des rapports qui
servent à calais les étagères moi je
veux que ces rapports parlementaires ne
servent pas qu'à calais les étagères
parce qu'ils sont souvent trans partisan
majorité-opposition donc appuyons nous
sur des travaux qui ont été faits dans
le temps qui amène du consensus et qui
me semblent solides pour justement fait
remettre des propositions de loi qui
irait dans le sens de l'intérêt général
pour donner peut-être la brutalité de ma
question mais est ce que c'est
réellement possible dans un régime comme
le nôtre avec un quinquennat qui est
calée sur les législatives sur la bande
nature est un chef de file forcément
très fort une présidente civilisation du
système
oui je le sais bien justement moi je ne
propose pas de grands bouleversements
certains disent il faut passer il faut
revenir au septennat il faut créer un
sextennat renouvela par renouvelables la
proportionnelle et c'est moi je ne
propose pas de grands bouleversements je
propose de rester dans notre cadre
institutionnel qui a montré sa solidité
et qui nous a permis de gérer des crises
très graves telles que celles que l'on
vient de vivre donc 1 400
institutionnels stabilisé mais justement
des changements de mécanique
parlementaire dit on pour renforcer le
parlement moi je pense qu'on peut rester
pour on peut réussir à conserver nos
équilibres tout en donnant un parlement
qui est plus de pouvoir plus de temps
pour légiférer tout le monde y gagnera
évidemment le gouvernement également
l'autre actualité surtout pour vous qui
présidait la commission des lois il ya
une propriété privée c'est cette tribune
tribune de magistrats qui a été publiée
dans le monde la semaine dernière sous
le titre nous voulons plus d'une justice
qui n'écoute pas et qui chronomètre tout
elle a reçu un vif succès plus de la
moitié des juges des procureurs du pays
l'ont signé est ce qu'il ya un problème
aujourd'hui entre l'exécutif et les
magistrats on sait que notre justice est
en souffrance ça n'est pas sa date
malheureusement pas d'hier nous avons
fait de nombreuses réformes nous avons
augmenté considérablement le budget de
la justice ce qui va nous permettre
d'embaucher des magistrats de les doter
de plus de moyens et nous sommes en ce
moment en train de mener les états
généraux de la justice je fais partie du
comité des garants donc nous avec
justement françois noël buffet mon
homologue au sénat et nous avons remis
un certain nombre de sujets sur la table
donc c'est bien que effectivement la
justice est au coeur de nos
préoccupations et tribunal va changer la
donne dans les états généraux de la
justice alors nous allons auditionner
les auteurs de cette tribune dès mardi
au comité des garants je sais qu'ils
l'ont été reçue par le garde des sceaux
nous ne pouvons pas fermer les yeux
lorsque nous avons une telle tribune
lorsque nous ressentons une telle
souffrance chez les magistrats parce que
ça concerne tout le monde parce que
chacun est peut être concerné un jour
par une affaire judiciaire et il voudra
avoir des magistrats qui sont à l'écouté
qui prenne le temps d'examiner son
affaire parce que une affaire n'est
jamais identique à une autre affaire
donc il nous faut avoir des magistrats
qu'ils puissent pleinement accomplir
leur mission cevital est donc cette
tribune il faut l'entendre il faut
essayer d'y répondre moi je me réjouis
que ces magistrats qui sont très
nombreux accepte ce dialogue accepte
d'être dents au sein des états généraux
de la justice parce que encore une fois
il ne s'agit pas d'avoir des solutions
qui tombe du ciel il faut qu'elles
soient partagées il faut qu'elle soit
élaboré ensemble donc il faut qu'on
travaille ensemble avec les magistrats
avec les avocats avec les justiciables
ce que nous faisons dans les états
généraux de la justice et fondamentaux
nous évoquer les avocats d'ailleurs vous
êtes avocat
triste alternativement on entend les
avocats s'étaient cas sous la halle à
ministère n'en belloubet cette fois on
entend beaucoup de les magistrats ça va
mieux du côté des invocations vous ça va
ça va bien avec avec les avocats nous
avons renouer un dialogue fructueux mais
il nous disait aussi leurs souffrances
leurs difficultés d'exercice les terry
joe letteri
c'est compliqué pour nous de leur
exercice professionnel dont on sait
qu'ils sont très différents selon
l'endroit où il exerce donc on voit bien
que l'injustice dans son ensemble avait
des difficultés qui remontait à très
loin donc nous essayons de prendre les
problèmes les uns après les autres et au
sein de ces états généraux d'être tous
ensemble pour avoir une justice qui
fonctionne mieux mais encore une fois
c'est dans l'intérêt de tous on va
parler de l'actualité politique chargé
un ces dernières heures on connaît donc
la fiche du second tour du congrès des
républicains c'est eric ciotti qui est
arrivé en tête qui affrontera valérie
pécresse zèle et pécresse qui part
favorite pour ce second tour puisqu'elle
a reçu le ralliement de l'ensemble des
candidats éliminés ce serait une
mauvaise nouvelle une très mauvaise
nouvelle pour pour emmanuel macron cette
candidature de valérie pécresse moi je
trouve que la mauvaise nouvelle c'est ce
résultat pour les républicains on voit
que le premier candidat donc celui qui
arrive en tête c'est un candidat qui
nous dit qu'entre emmanuel macron eric
zemmour il voterait eric zemmour c'est
un candidat qui nous dit qu'il croit en
la théorie du grand emplacement c'est un
candidat qui nous dit qu'ils souhaitent
à guantanamo à la française et c'est lui
qui arrive en tête chez les républicains
donc je crois quand même que les
républicains sont vraiment passés d'un
côté
de droite pour ultra est restée quatre
grands blocs à trembler mais comme les
chez les écologistes finalement donc on
est dans un résultat de primaire qui dit
qui montre des parties très divisé et
qui fait une donne une prime à la
radicalité j'ajoute que valérie pécresse
n'est pas en reste moi j'ai vu des
projets de réforme constitutionnelle
uniquement porté sur l'immigration
qu'elle a soutenu pendant sa campagne
elle prône la suppression des
allocations familiales aux personnes
étrangères qui sont sur notre territoire
pendant un laps de temps de cinq ans
donc on voit bien est proposée système
de quotas par exemple sur l'immigration
pour dans lequel je cite on sélectionne
ce que l'on veut laisser entrer sur
territoire français dans ce système de
jeu pour l'immigration économique il
avait été évoqué par edouard philippe il
avait été un temps envisagée finalement
ça n'a pas été fait ce ne serait pas une
solution que le parlement fait chaque
année des quotas alors là ce qu'on sait
en fait c'est que l'immigration
économique c'est vraiment une toute
petite partie de l'immigration
aujourd'hui la grande masse de
l'immigration qui arrivent en france
c'est des gens jeunes qui viennent
étudier en france et nous avons besoin
d'avoir des étudiants entrant étrangers
parce qu'il nous faut former aussi les
élites des pays qui sont aujourd'hui en
difficulté et qui sont pourvoyeurs
d'immigration il faut les aider à se
développer par de l'aide économique mais
par la formation de leurs futures élites
et c'est ce que nous faisons aussi en
accueillant des étudiants étrangers et
puis c'est le regroupement familial
moi j'y crois et je suis convaincu
qu'aujourd'hui la famille c'est
important est que nous ne pouvons pas
séparer des familles durablement en
durcissant drastiquement les règles du
regroupement familial c'est également ce
que propose monsieur eric sautier madame
pécresse donc on a des visions très
différentes encore une fois moi je pense
que c'est une mauvaise nouvelle pour les
républicains de cette plongée dans cette
radicalité là et sur la lutte pour
lutter contre l'immigration clandestine
pour vous il ne faut pas changer la
constitution
écoutez encore une fois - la
constitution c'est ce qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui on a un état de droit
solide qui est solide sur ses valeurs
sûres ces grands principes sur ses
droits et libertés et on voit bien que
pendant les crises sanitaires pendant
les crises terroristes c'est la
constitution et le conseil
constitutionnel qui nous perd être de
rester dans ce cadre là et moi je crois
et je ne suis jamais vu même à évoluer
le conseil constitutionnel notamment
pour gérer les terroristes sorte en
prison quand j'ai appelé le conseil
constitutionnel a évolué c'était sur son
canot procédurales c'était pour appeler
à plus de contradictoire jeu n'appelait
pas à une évolution qui soit sur le fond
et qui touche nos principes nos droits
et libertés contrairement à éric ciotti
va errer pékin dernier mot sur valérie
pécresse a là une autre proposition
c'est la territorialisation des peines
c'est à dire selon les taux de
criminalité dans certains endroits du
territoire national en clair le lieu où
est commis le délit serait considéré
comme une circonstance aggravante qu'est
ce que vous pensez de ça moi je crois
comprendre avec l inde l elle indique
que c'est parfaitement constitutionnel
moi j'ai de sérieux doutes sur la
constitutionnalité d'une telle mesure
puisque la loi doit s'appliquer partout
de la même façon à tous nos concitoyens
justement la loi elle est là pour
présenter un cadre général et après les
magistrats sont là pour avoir une
appréciation particulière lié à la
personnalité de l'individu et aux faits
commis donc je ne crois pas qu'un qu'une
telle mesure ni swiss ne soient
efficaces ni ne soit juridiquement
solide c'est plutôt bien parti pour
valérie pécresse au deuxième tour compte
tenu de la paix la beauté de ses
concurrentes pour elle au deuxième tour
il est fort probable qu elles
l'emportent ce week-end on sait que
marine le pen sera également présente
lance dans cette campagne présidentielle
c'est le cas d'anne hidalgo s'est
beaucoup de femmes se c'est plutôt une
bonne nouvelle pour vous cette
féminisation de la campagne
présidentielle alors c'est une bonne
nouvelle d'une façon générale la
féminisation de la vie politique on voit
qu'on a un mouvement qui est
irrésistible les femmes politiques
prennent des responsabilités de plus en
plus grande des candidates président
maire présidente de commission à
l'assemblée nous sommes sur des des
présidences de commission paritaire des
ministères on a un gouvernement qui est
parfaitement paritaire le numéro deux du
gouvernement est une femme donc je crois
qu'effectivement c'est une bonne chose
c'est un mouvement qui j'espère ne
s'arrêtera pas encore une marche à
franchir
encore une marche à franchir que ce soit
en politique mais que ce soit aussi au
sein de nos grandes institutions
nous n'avons jamais encore eu de femme
président de la cour des comptes
président du conseil constitutionnel
vice-présidente du conseil d'état donc
vous voyez qu'on a encore cette petite
mais président de la république ni
présidente de la cs un paillis sera
candidate pour la république en marche a
priori m'écouter évidemment moi je
souhaite que le président de la
république soit candidat pour nous nous
nous sommes rassemblés nous souhaitons
être derrière lui et puis j'espère qu'il
le sera merci beaucoup merci alors
refusé d'avoir été de travail était ce
matin
[Musique]